you might think of gun control and feel
or you might think of gun control and
things from my cold dead what you
probably don't think of is racism but
the history of gun control is a history
riddled with racial discrimination and
some irony in his 2011 book gunfight UCL
a professor of law adam winkler argued
gun control measures have been tied to
anti black discrimination for most of
the country's history before the Civil
War the right to own guns it came with
the right to own black slaves after the
Civil War black Americans were finally
able to own guns which made many white
Americans fear and armed rebellion in
fact the KKK was founded in part to
seize the arms of blacks in the south
one of the biggest irony
today in the gun control debate is that
groups that once supported strict gun
control measures now posed them like the
National Rifle Association this gun
loving organization didn't always fight
for the right of all Americans to own
guns in the 1920s the NRA promoted
restrictive laws that only allowed
suitable people with proper reason to
own firearms because of a spike in urban
crime and in the eyes of law enforcement
immigrants especially Italian Americans
were not necessarily the most suitable
with the most proper reasons to own guns
the sports the civil rights movement
where black Americans were resisting
state enforced violence not
coincidentally this was also the era
when major gun control measures were
passed until 1967 California a state
that today has some of the strictest gun
laws in the country was in fact open
carry during that time the resistance
group the Black Panthers began openly
arming its members and patrolling for
police abuses on the streets of Oakland
the images of armed black activists
created a frenzy and then California
Governor Ronald Reagan and the NRA
supported legislation that ended the
right to openly carry guns in the state
then there were two major assassinations
in nineteen
sixty-eight Martin Luther King jr. and
Robert F Kennedy believing that easy
access to guns was partly to blame for
the assassinations and some of the race
riots that followed the federal
government passed the most expansive gun
control measures in decades the Gun
Control Act of 1968 today the politics
of gun control have shifted dramatically
but race still plays a role consider
this when American politicians the NRA
and certain conservative groups and
militias want their guns for protection
the question to ask is protection from
who